what is going on everybody welcome to
part 8 of our Python with pine qt4
tutorial video series in this video
we're going to be talking about is the
adding a checkbox as well as adding some
event handling for that checkbox just to
give us even more comfortable with event
handling with that let's go ahead and
hop right in so a checkbox can be a lot
of things a checkbox can it's usually
some sort of a toggle for maybe some
sort of setting that someone may want or
may not want and so on for us this is
the only this is the first one at least
so far that makes really no sense for me
to make the checkbox exit the
application so we're going to make it do
something else but I'm going to show you
how you can use it to modify your
application so for example let's uh
we're going to add this to edit a home
and we'll just do it right below our
toolbar and of course before self dot
show it can be easy to like modify your
method and then like start um modifying
it here after the show so don't do that
and let's just do check box like that
equals cutie GUI cue checkbox and then
you can specify what you want the check
box to set we're going to make ours
enlarge the window and self so that adds
the check box now what we need to do is
check boxes have a state they are either
on or off it's a boolean state so to
check that we do check box dot state
changed dot connect self dot enlarged
window okay and that's that so then we
need a enlarge window method so let's
add our in large window method
and in fact to make this a proper method
we're supposed to do that trying my best
to stay pet bait
someone's probably be like that's not
bad bait anyway define enlarge
underscore window so and now we have
basically a question either either the
state is checked or it's not checked so
what we can say is if state equals in
fact in large window and then comma
state and then yeah that should be
enough in large window colonists a yes
so if state equals cutie court cutie dot
checked oh my goodness I type of that
twice in a row a self dot set geometry
and then we're going to change it will
keep the window in the same initial
location but now we'll make it a
thousand by six hundred so we're just
doubling the window size else self dot
set geometry fifty fifty five hundred
three hundred now let us that should be
good actually so let's go ahead and run
that and see how we do okay well we
first of always see it's of course in in
the way of our file but let's click it
anyways and as you can see it makes the
window bigger so let's close this and
let me go back where did we initially
set our geometry fifty-fifty so let's
run that one more time
oh I had moved the window I was trying
to figure out like how that's where it
went up okay so that was my fault now
let's let's move this checkbox over and
maybe down a little bit so what we can
do is right under here we can say the
check check box dot move and dot move
please thank you move and remove it
let's move it 100 over and maybe 15 down
something like that maybe a little more
down let's do 20
that's good enough around so now we can
make it bigger smaller cool now
sometimes people might want to know well
maybe what if you wanted to check box
like this check box is not by default
toggled but you might have an instance
where the default is toggled what do you
do well first of all what you would do
should be simple as checkbox dot toggle
possibly let's try that very quick
toggle right so now it's automatically
checked if you notice but the window
isn't any friggin bigger what gives well
if we look over here we can see that the
question that we asked is check box dot
state changed so the reason why this
isn't really working it depends on what
your logic and your defaults are right
but this will only be triggered if the
state has changed and the initial is we
were just hogging it on or off so if the
initial state is to be toggled off then
uh then the initial State
you know it's off and then so clicking
it would make it do you know a positive
action but instead like if you wanted it
off you would say you know you could
toggle this off and then you would
basically flip these flip these
scenarios around you know so if you
wanted to have something off by default
just keep that in mind but just visually
if you want to toggle it or not you can
by default it's not toggled but if you
want it to be to be toggled you would
just you know turn this off and then
maybe instead of enlarged you might have
a shrink window right and then you could
leave it toggled right and then the
window would shrink it you know if you
untold' it let's say or if you untitled
it now then it would get bigger right so
anyway before I confuse myself any more
than I've already confused myself the
point is you can toggle it in advance or
not but just keep in mind the event
handling if you do so moving on for my
head blows oh that's our check box how
you can make it do stuff and just you
know making the window bigger or smaller
so if you have any questions or comments
up to this point please feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time